[Music]
hundreds of truckers continue to roll
east and with more joining the movement
with each passing city feelings towards
vaccine mandates have heightened i
advocate civil war
if people don't want to stand up we've
got guns we'll stand up and we'll bring
them out while this sentiment is shared
by a fraction of protesters it's visible
in their social media discussions with
some calling for canada's version of the
january 6th insurrection this national
security expert says it's unlikely the
so-called freedom convoy is as organized
as what happened in the u.s capitol but
the rhetoric that we're seeing hanging
politicians driving trucks through
16-foot walls this kind of stuff is
disturbing and definitely will be on the
minds i think of security officials
going forward on tuesday police forces
in saskatchewan noted about 1200 semis
were part of the convoy and more are
joining with drivers coming from the
maritimes quebec and ontario
demonstration associated to the freedom
convoy police agencies in ottawa are
preparing the city's police service held
an emergency meeting with its council
addressing concerns in case the
demonstration becomes restless but one
political analyst says canadians are
looking for clarity around pandemic
measures far fewer canadians are
interested in in
[Music]
demonstrating in in ottawa and and fewer
still are interested in in trying to
foment any kind of violence the canadian
trucking alliance noted about 90 percent
of drivers are vaccinated meaning they
won't face a quarantine period if
crossing the border the transport
minister says the government worked with
the industry when creating this policy
so this was the right time to encourage
the remainder of our truck drivers the
remaining number of our truck drivers to
get vaccinated omar algabra added it was
also in line with similar measures in
the u.s one of the convoys organizers is
calling for a peaceful protest and that
extreme voices don't reflect their
position
kyle benning
global news